let me see if I can follow along with
you right the first thing I'm going to
do is it's not a quadratic something to
turn into one look I'm going to reduce
it down so here is my substitution okay
now by the way this step as with many
steps it's kind of like hmm I'm trying
to think through what I'm doing but as
you get more comfortable with this you
don't have to say explicitly your do it
you can do some of these steps in your
head as you become more familiar with
them okay so i'm going to write my new
equation in here that's that again it's
1 i've chosen which is easy to factorize
what's the pair of numbers are Martha
minus minus 2 positive 3 will that work
for me when I do minus 2 plus 3 that's
going to give me one right which is
supposed to be dis number it here but
it's not quite matching up I need a
different pair of factors going to close
yeah 600 is one well 6 and minus 1 do it
for me when you add them six plus
negative ones you get five you do right
and when you do 6 times negative 1 do
you get minus 6 yeah you do it checks
out okay so therefore i'm rather than
this i'm going to go 6 and negative 1 so
I get you + 6 u minus 1 equals 0 are you
happy with that ok so now I can go ahead
and soul minus 1 sorry was it one or
negative 6 okay yeah yeah I'm in U
squared plus 5 you so it wasn't fuzzy
sweater oh sorry yeah that's right said
better thanks okay so I've done by now
I've done my sausage incorrectly I
factorize I've gotten a pair of
solutions out for you ok so now I have
to go back don't I I have to go back to
here and i have to say m squared instead
of you alright so there's my one all i
need u 6 now once you get to this point
you might raise an eyebrow right i think
hold on something a bit strange is going
to happen here um does it start off too
bad if you just imagine x squared with
one and that's what you have what
solutions are you going to get out for
that
you're just going to get plus or minus
the square root is one which happens to
be one right so you deal okay but then
you get through this next part and you
say hold on a second there's no number
at least not the way from the area
there's no number you can square no real
number that when you square it gives you
a negative right because if you take the
square root of six if you square that
guy you won't get negative six you'll
get six right if you take the negative
square root of six if you square that
you're still in trouble because that
double negative will cancel and you'll
still get positive 6 there's nothing we
can do to come up with an answer for
this right so therefore out of the one
we get plus or minus one out of the
negative six though it doesn't actually
contribute any solutions that's it I'm
finished even though we expected and
it's a good read with good reason we
expected for solutions right we've only
gotten two and that does happen
sometimes that's fine okay in fact you
can it doesn't take that much effort to
imagine if I shuffle around my numbers a
little bit if I had two negative numbers
here like saying negative 1 or negative
6 what would that mean for this final
answer here how many solutions would
there be there wouldn't be any solutions
that I can deal with in these kinds of
numbers right because there's no numbers
icann Square to get to negative 1 and no
numbers I can cook square to get to
negative 6 at least not on my graph ok
now just out of the sake of our
curiosity just so you can see what this
means what this would look like is
square root is about 1.4 okay so you're
gonna get a graph that looks something
like this or something yeah okay
something like that for this because
you've got a higher power up here just
Wiggles more right just like a parabola
Wiggles once and just goes off this guy
Wiggles a few more times okay here
what's going to happen because you only
got two solutions and you'll get a shape
color it's what's this possible is one
okay it's still Wiggles three goes
around right but you see how I've got
one
two three four solutions kia but over
here i've only got 2 12 it just means
this regal happens too high or too low
or something else so that it never
actually intersects ok